hello everyone and welcome to our talk
on fly brain lab
an interactive open computing platform
for exploring the drosophila brain
my name is mehmet karam turkja i am a
phd candidate at bionet lab in the
electrical engineering department at
columbia university
i am presenting this work on behalf of
my research advisor ora lazar
and my lab mates tinkai leo and ian zhao
we are grateful to have this unique
opportunity to share with you our work
on exploring
modeling and comparing models of the
brain of drosophila
without further ado let's begin you
might be asking right now
what is drosophila
drosophila or specifically the species
drosophila melanogaster that we study
are well-known common pests and
households that are attracted to rotten
fruits into which they lay their eggs
this has led to their popular name their
common fruit fly
drosophila is a popular model organism
and research
and historically five nobel prizes have
been awarded
to a total of nine scientists for their
research based on the fruit fly
the long-lasting popularity of the fruit
fly has led to a huge amount of data
on the structure of its brain its
behavior and its genetics
rendering it a good subject for
neuroscience research
to be more specific for drosophila we
have an
immense amount of data on its brain
throughout different stages of
development
which allows us to pinpoint lineages of
different neurons
we have a great world of data on the
brain regions
or neuropills that make up the brain and
how they are connected
we know a lot about how different cells
can be classified into types
based on their morphology primary
neurotransmitters
function or genetics in addition to
having the capability to record the
activity of neurons
we also know about the behavioral
repertoire of drosophila
and the groups of neurons associated
with these behaviors
finally in the last few years data on
the neural circuits in the brain at
single sign-up scale
is now starting to become available
which gives us
neurons and how they are connected
allowing us to explore neural circuits
in unprecedented levels of detail and
form hypotheses about their function
especially when coupled with the rest of
this data
we expect the whole drosophila brain to
be available in the next few years
in the meantime we work with three
specific data sets
in particular
the first data sets we've worked with
and the first dataset we historically
started to work with
is the so-called fly circuit dataset the
first version of which was published in
2011.
fly circuit data set is composed of
about 20 000 randomly sampled neurons
from different specimens
registered to a common brain template
for many years it has been central to
researchers that study information flow
between fly brain regions but it fails
to support further advances in
understanding the functional logic of
neural circuits for several reasons
number one the uniqueness of each neuron
and the completeness of neurons within a
neuron type could not
be established because each neuron is
randomly sampled from a different
individual number two the data set does
not have synaptic connections
which means we don't know how neurons
are connected to one another
each of the 10 lines you see here is
part of the so-called skeleton of a
single neuron
and in this custom render we have
thousands of the fly circuit neurons
present
at the center is the so-called central
brain
and the two parts to the side are the
visual system
the second data set we work with was
released in january this year
and it took us a week after its release
to integrate the data set into our
platform
the have a brain data set the extent of
which i am showing only approximately
here
to give an idea of its size is a high
resolution data set that contains more
than 20 000
traced neurons and synapses between them
the quality of these tracings as well as
the annotation of the cell types
provided by the maintainers
has greatly extended our knowledge about
how neural circuits in the central brain
are wired
finally a collaborative project has been
going on to image and trace the neurons
and their synaptic connections
in the brain of larva drosophila over
the last few years
due to the similarity of certain
structures in the brain of larval
drosophila to the adult
as well as its capability for a range of
interesting behaviors
drosophila larva is popular we are
interested in using this data for
comparative studies and for
understanding common capabilities of the
adult
and the larva
as an illustration of what we do with
this data
let me present an example about the
early visual system of drosophila
drosophila have a compound eye structure
composed of about 750 so called omatidia
if we were to focus on what is going on
right within one of these
material we would observe a structure
like this in which different neurons are
colored with
different colors these are the neural
circuits whose computational structure
we are interested in for us these are
circuits not composed of transistors but
rather of neurons
and synapses these executable circuits
can be interrogated to understand how
neural circuits function
historically there has been a lack of
structural data on the wiring of these
circuits
and with the data sets that i was
describing just a moment ago
this limitation is no longer there
however
all of the structural data today
is served in different formats that are
difficult to parse
and sometimes require heavy domain
expertise to process
and format into neural circuits like
what i'm showing here in the second row
now i would like to explain our main
interest in all of this data
their integration and circuit
construction
as computational neuroscientists our
main goal is to understand brains
to understand brains we have to
understand how neural circuits perform
computation
to do so we want to use the information
we have on these circuits
rather than black box approaches to
constrain our models appropriately and
achieve better correspondences in order
to discover the computational features
of these circuits that generalize beyond
the experiments
in this quest it is of value to know
what these circuits
actually look like now our discussion so
far
perhaps masks the greatest challenge
facing us as computational researchers
and that is the lack of a central
ecosystem that brings all of this data
together
gives people access to them from a
python kernel with consistent data
formats
integrates this data with simulations to
make the neurons modeled
transparent so that the features of the
models can be compared against
the neural circuits to judge their
hidden assumptions
fly brainlab provides within a single
working
environment 3d visualization and
exploration of connection data
interactive exploration
of executable circuit diagrams and
real-time code execution
this brings us to what fly brain lab
looks like
i will describe fly brain lab by
starting with our front end which we
call neurominora
now again here is our concept of what we
seek to accomplish
and here is how we implemented it this
is the user interface
that we use for our research on neural
circuit exploration
execution and comparison this is
neurominerva the front end of flybrine
lab
built on top of jupiter lab on the
screen you see a couple of widgets for
visualizing structural data
and computational models for the fruit
fly brain
i will go over them one by one but first
i want to get this out of the way the
visualization widgets we provide are
associated with specific
python kernels connected to notebooks
which can be treated as standard
notebooks
every data view visualize can be
accessed from the python kernel
or requested via documented python apis
and neural circuits you explore can be
compiled into executable models that can
be customized and run on gpus using
flybrandlab
we use a custom simulation library we
call neurokernel
and the neural circuit implementation
library called neurodriver to implement
these models and the library code in
robalid for simplifying circuit
specification
jupyterlab's built in local file access
panel is also quite convenient
for the computational work that we do
for visualization of neural morphology
and metadata we have two widgets
the neural nlp window allows us to use
natural language queries to retrieve
data from data sets
and the info panel contains a large
variety of data on a neuron including
its partner
here i will give an example of the
interface in action
showing these two widgets when you open
fly brain lab
you will see an option to create an fbl
or fly brain lab workspace
clicking on this you will be prompted to
choose the data set that you would like
to connect to by default
here i will choose the fly circuit data
set
which will load the associated brain
regions
you are free to customize your workspace
however you want
for this demo i will maximize the neural
nlp vendor
i will then simply write show neurons
in the ellipsoid body where ellipsoid
body is a region in the drosophila brain
the neurons will be retrieved from the
backend and their morphology will be
visualized
i can rotate my screen i can hover over
neurons to highlight them
but more importantly i can click on them
to actually retrieve
information about them as you can see
this information contains their unique
name
their database the synaptic partners
that are inferred using an
algorithm that i'm not going into to
detail here
i can use this list of neurons that they
are connected to
to bring in these partners into my
workspace
this is just a simple demo demonstrating
how you can construct neural circuits
during exploration
using neurominerva
now i would like to describe how we have
implemented the capabilities we have
just looked at
now the data that you see come up in
flybrian lab is data coming from our
graph database neural arc which can be
running on the same computer or on a
user designated server
your arc is built on top of orient db
and nodes in the graph correspond to
neuron synapses computational models
neurotransmitters brain regions and more
this information is used in queries to
return all available information on a
neuron
which can be accessed from the info
panel or directly as a
python dictionary via using our api
this data contains information such as
name of the
database the neuron is coming from its
name it's 3d morphology as you can see
to the left
the database reference id cell type
its neurotransmitter if it is known
number of synapses it doesn't
on each brain region a number of
neighboring
neurons and number of synapses between
this neuron and that neuron circuits
modeling this neuron
and computational models used to model
this neuron
in these circuits and finally
morphometric data such as surface area
volume etc
the neural nlp interface has many more
capabilities than just
showing something you can remove neurons
matching a certain characteristic or
keep on the dose matching one
here i remove gaborgic neurons first
and then choose to keep only the
glutamatergic neurons
further filtering what i have in my
current workspace
one can also choose to show neurons
connecting different brain regions to
one another
since as i have shown we track this
information in our database as well
secondly we have the neuro gfx window
which allows us to visualize neural
circuits
with interactive circuit diagrams rather
than talking about these capabilities i
will show an example
using the same material example i have
presented earlier
we can click on the laminar region in
the circuit diagram of the entire fly
brain
which you can see at the bottom half of
the screen to go to the lamina
and double clicking on what we observe
again
i uh we enter into a single or material
flybring lab circuit diagrams are
programmable
and the circuit diagram automatically
finds the neurons whose descriptions
exist
in this svg file and brings them to our
workspace
we associate a number of elemental
operations with these diagrams
clicking on an active element will
disable it
and remove the neuron from our are
simulations
these changes are reflected in the
python kernel
and can be used to study the effects of
disabling a neuron
on the neural circuit
i want to mention that fly brain lab was
built to enable many different kinds of
interactive circuit visualizations based
on different circuits
and over time we have created a large
variety of scripts
for using as a as a way to visualize
circuits
for example here i am showing a diagram
for the whole
early visual system of the fly based on
the connectomics data
in which additional user given
information
allows for neurons to be distributed to
different rows based on their neurals
but this can be customized visually and
adapted for different circuits if you
wanted to
secondly here i am showing the diagram
we have created for the entire central
complex
a multi-neuropal structure in the
drosophila brain
this was a custom diagram that was
designed in inkscape
for which we use the svg element
properties and the script to add
interactivity to the diagram
the example that i was showing earlier
is similarly based on a custom svg file
lastly we provide examples for using
interactive diagrams from the connectom
data retrieved from the neural arc
database
using python scripts for which for which
we provide standardized scripts
enabling interactivity
these three different methods of circuit
construction i have mentioned have some
common features
in terms of circuit interactivity
clicking on neurons in a diagram allows
for adding them to
or removing them from the workspace
these changes are reflected
in the computational model secondly
users can create hierarchical diagrams
where nodes do not only correspond to
neurons i will show an example to this
later
finally it is possible to add the
capability to change the model
parameters or computational models of
individual components
from the front end
now that i have presented the
capabilities we provide in the front end
i want to briefly talk about the
architecture of fly brain lab
so far i have talked about neura minerva
which forms the user side front end i am
presenting
at the top row the second row
i just unveiled shows what we have in
the user side back end
of these components the flybring lab
client
is the one that communicates with our
servers
we use the crossbar library to
communicate with the server
retrieve data parse it and send it to
minerva our server software is also
written in python and contains our
database
commands from the flybrainlab client are
interpreted
executed and the results are sent back
either at once
or in chunks when the data is too large
in practice we find the neuron
morphology requests and simulation
results retrieval to be
to such cases in which data needs to be
retrieved in chunks
importantly i want to mention that
flybrainlab is designed with modularity
in mind
supporting users and developers with
different technical backgrounds
with remote access to the vacant servers
anywhere in the world
on the left i am showing the different
proficiencies that are in demand for
helping with the development of our
platform
that those interested in helping
computational neuroscience can
contribute to
finally it is our hope that the
accessibility of jupiter lab as an
environment
makes it easier for newcomers to be
introduced to the modern challenges in
computational neuroscience way of
librarian lab
before moving on to examples showing
some sample circuits we have created and
simulation results
i want to briefly show the capabilities
we enable
via a number of utility libraries we
have created to better analyze the data
retrieved from the database during our
exploration
flybrainlab features a number of utility
libraries that
aim to make it easier to work with the
data retrieved from the servers firstly
there is the neural embed
library which creates node embeddings
for a graph in which neurons are nodes
and synapses are edges
on the left i am showing a bunch of
neurons closely connected with one
another
on the right i am showing the output of
one of the models implemented in neural
embed
which embeds neurons in a 2d space in
which closeness of nodes is highly
predictive
of their human annotated cell types we
have used heldard cell types to see how
model
how well our model worked in this
scenario these groups
can then be analyzed and interrogated to
see how
correct human annotations are or to find
new new types of cells
secondly we have the neurograph library
which allows for the discovery of
connectivity patterns
by using community detection or
clustering algorithms and specified
neural circuits
here i am showing the adjacency matrix
of more than twenty thousand neurons in
the hemibrain data set
ordered according to communities
extracted by applying the levain
algorithm using neurograph
we have more libraries for data
visualization
querying in python and for generating
morphometric measurements for individual
neurons
uh when that data is available such as
axon length
surface area or neuron value
with flybrainlab we seek to provide the
unified environment for the development
of brain circuit models
for the remaining part of this talk i
will go over two case studies of
circuits that we have
looked at as examples to the
capabilities of library and lab
the subject of our first study will be
the central complex
the sub-circuits of which have appeared
before in this presentation
we have created a highly complex circuit
diagram
that replicates our observations about
the circuitry of the central complex
we can highlight regions so by hovering
over them
or we can click on regions to ablate
entire regions at once corresponding to
multiple neurons
secondly our diagram as i'm about to
show in a second
is hierarchical allowing us to enter
into regions and observe how groups of
neurons are connected to one another
in these sub-circuits as you can see
in this quest we have started with a
work that was published in 2017
by former members of our lab
using a slightly different and
interesting input stimulus
now with an additional but stationary
bar
that is lower in intensity at 60 degree
angle to the fly
we can simulate the response of the
ellipsoid body
we find that the ellipsoid where the
activity pattern can still track the
location of the input pattern in the
scenario
we repeated the same process of model
development and simulation
for two other models of the central
complex from literature
shown here in the middle and right
columns
these three concurrently published
models each describe a different subset
of the neurons in the central complex
as visualized by the corresponding
neurons in the
in the bottom row in this video
we show three circuits side by side
showing the notebooks
the neural nlp morphology visualizations
and the circuit diagrams corresponding
to these three different models
note that for the specific circuit
diagram hovering over neurons
shows additional modeling information
for the loaded executable
model which is a feature of the circuit
diagram
towards the end of this video we also
show the simulation results and let me
fast forward to that section
and as you can see by running some
scripts we can generate these
visualizations
employing the methodology i have just
shown and using the same
input to all three models we perform the
comparative study of their input and
output behaviors we see that although
there are some slight differences in
their response patterns
all three models show the tracking
behavior of the ellipsoid body quite
well
we then looked at the the shared circuit
features that these models all capture
that allowed us to pinpoint the key
circuit features giving rise to this
behavior
we encourage you to read our preprint
for these details similarly
we can use flybrainlab to compare models
of the same species
across developmental stages or datasets
to shed light on the scaling principles
here for our second case study we have
looked at the earlier factory system of
the fruit fly
in three different data sets and used
connectivity patterns between the cell
types to construct
similar but slightly different
executable circuits
the earlier factor system of drosophila
consists of a number of parallel
subcircuits whose receptor neurons
express
different olfactory receptors olfactory
system of drosophila is intensely
studied
and we know a lot about the cells
forming the early olfactory systems for
both adult
and larval drosophila here i am showing
the neurons retrieved using
flybrainlab queries from two different
datasets we have
we have integrated known facts about the
circuit and our observations
from the query results to create
executable models
our model suggests that the activity of
the so-called projection neurons
downstream of the olfactory sensory
neurons in each of these subcircuits
are normalized in some sense and encode
the relative affinity of their olfactory
receptor and the delivered ordinance
to the affinities of all other olfactory
receptors
in both adult and larval flies
to be more clear we find that for
both of these circuits despite their
differences
the projection neuron or pn responses
are more similar to the affinity which
is in some sense
the input to olfactory sensory neurons
rather than the responses of the
olfactory sensory neurons themselves
whose activity patterns look different
this is
interesting as pians receive all factory
inputs from oss
directly all of these model development
analysis and comparison examples we have
went over
whether it's between models from
different publications using the same
data set
or between data sets or even between
developmental stages
are significantly accelerated by the
integration brought about by the fly
brain lab platform
recently we have used flybrainlab as a
tool for education on computational
neuroscience
in the computing with brain circuits of
model organisms course
offered in columbia university
thank you for listening to our talk i
want to conclude by stating that in this
age of widespread open data releases
there is a big opportunity in
computational neuroscience for exploring
mapping and understanding neural
circuits of the fruit fly brain
on a level of detail that will not be
possible for other organisms for years
if you are interested to learn more
about our work
you can read our preprints download fly
brain lab code on github explore our
website
or follow us on twitter and again thanks
for listening to our